divide and simplify the answer and write
it and write it i guess right as a mixed
number so we have four divided by two
thirds and we've seen when you divide by
the fraction it's the same thing as
multiplying by its reciprocal so this is
going to be the same thing as 4
as 4 times the reciprocal of 2 3 which
is 3 over 2 just swapping the bottom and
the top number the denominator and the
numerator now
four you you know we've seen this before
where we're saying okay well if we know
how to multiply fractions you multiply
the numerators times each other and the
denominator times each other but four
doesn't look like a fraction but you
always have to remember a whole number
can be written as that same whole number
over 1. 4 is the same thing as 4
over 1. and now this becomes
kind of a plain vanilla multiplying
fractions problem and so we could just
multiply it out we could just say that
this is 4 times 3 which would be 12 over
1 times 2 which would be 2
or we could we could divide right now
well we could let's do it both ways
actually so we could say this is 4 times
3 in the numerator which is 12
over 1 times 2 in the denominator which
is 2. now what is 12 divided by 2 12
over 2 is the same thing as 12 divided
by 2. well this is equal to this is
equal to 6. or another way we could
think about it another way to think
about it is divide the numerator by 2
well that would give you 6 and divide
the denominator by 2. that'll give you
1. 6 over 1 which is the same thing as
6. now the other thing we could have
done at this stage right here we said
well look we have things in the
numerator divisible by 2. we have things
in the denominator divisible by two so
let's divide both by two so four divided
by two is two
two divided by two is one so it becomes
two times three which is six
over
one times one over one or this is equal
to six now this could be a fun one to
visualize so let's think about what this
this is four divided by two thirds let's
do four let's draw four boxes here
let me do this so let's say i have one
two
let me do it separate them a little bit
one
two
three
and four
and you could view four divided by two
thirds let's divide these four boxes
into groups of two-thirds of a box and
figure out how many groups do we have so
where are groups so let's see if we want
the first group is going to have
two-thirds of a box in it so the first
group is going to look like this it's
going to have
two-thirds of a box now the next group
is going to have two-thirds of a box so
it'll have one-third from here
and then we'll have one-third from the
next box then the next group is going to
have two-thirds of the box there's
two-thirds left right over here
then the box the group after that will
have another two-thirds of a box
that is that right over there then the
next group will have one-third from here
and one-third from here so it'll have
one-third from here and one-third from
here that'll be two-thirds and then the
last group will have two-thirds the
leftover on this blocks right here now
how many groups of two-thirds do we have
we have
one
two
three
four five six so we have six four can be
divided into six groups of two-thirds so
it's just like regular division
sometimes a little harder to visualize
because we're dealing with fractions